okay let's get this thing going
everybody take a seat we've gotta have
more meetings homes cause I'm telling
you man we got to get working nice
Carlito ain't got a seed man someone get
him a chair no I'm cool
no dude get him a chair hose nah man I'm
gonna sit gangster but Carlito it
doesn't look like it's comfortable man
why don't you just sit in the chair
I never seen in no chair ese mm-hmm you
never ever gonna catch me sitting in no
chairs I guess that you know that that's
loco right oh it's cool Carlito no one's
gonna think you're soft if you sit in a
chair yes we're all sitting in chairs
bunch of bitch-ass cool arrows okay I
don't have no time to sit in a cane
chair okay not that we're all here
you know what about Y dog like it don't
make no sense for you to set yourself up
with a rule like that no it's like
limiting they're limiting ah sometimes
people sit in chairs man all of you guys
with your bitch-ass chairs okay Carlito
quit playing and sit in the chair
pendejo no Carlito we have to have this
meeting now ese get up I'm good right
here man you know I'm chillin go ahead
with your meeting okay but you know it's
gonna be weird you don't get us gonna be
weird weird for you maybe he doesn't
care
okay okay homies so this is what we have
to do like we gotta sell more drugs and
we gotta make more crimes happen Roberta
thought we're a calico
you're bleeding ese yo you just got
shanked man we gotta pull that out leave
it I'm chilling homes I don't care about
that stupid shank
Toledo
little wake up man don't even bother
it's a he teachers meet you I don't need
those defibrillator I don't even want to
come back to life homes gallito go back
into your body my body's stupid homes
I'm fine right here on the spirit plane
life is for [ __ ]
[Music]
Kelly - Kelly - cool tonight nah I'm
good man
pollito does heaven man I don't need to
go to heaven Homs heaven is for [ __ ]
oh boy
you